don't worry I'm not going to do any  jokes about the Supreme Court ruling I  had a couple I just you know I didn't  think they were ready so I  [Applause]  okay very seriously what I had to do  what was best for me you know  I don't know if you guys understand how  hard it is to raise a premise to a setup  to a punch line it takes a lot of  time and love and care and I just didn't  love it like that you know what I mean I  didn't know if I could give it the love  it needed the resources it needed you  know what I mean I just I'm a single  comic out here  foreign  and I have other premises to raise so it  wasn't  it wasn't an easy decision but at the  end of the day I had to terminate the  punch line and that's just what that was  [Applause]